foreign
oh my gosh
the first image from the James Webb
Space Telescope and here it is all right
galaxies to the Edge of Time
oh my gosh you know how big and Airy
this is on the sky take a grain of sand
hold it at arm's length and ask how much
of the sky does that cover
this is the area covered by that grain
of sand as seen by the James Webb Space
Telescope a million miles from Earth oh
my gosh oh by the way there's some spiky
stuff here these are just Stars sitting
on our nose on our own Milky Way galaxy
and it's called diffraction spikes and
it happens from the hardware inside the
telescope so just ignore these look at
everything else that's in this image
especially they're galaxies that take
the shape of arcs
these are really distant galaxies whose
language is minding their own business
and they happen to move by a
supermassive cluster of galaxies halfway
to us and in moving through the fabric
of space and time they got distorted
because of the gravity of this super
cluster oh my gosh and so it forms arcs
that make a circular pattern around the
center of the image there's a lot going
on here oh my gosh just congratulations
to NASA the thousands of scientists
engineers Northrop Grumman and everybody
else who made this real bringing the
universe down to earth
keep looking up
all right how about right there
now we're kind of done with the Hubble
is still doing some work but it's not
like groundbreaking like when it was
first launched okay so we have the next
generation of the Hubble Space Telescope
okay and used to be called the ngst the
Next Generation
okay and then we find somebody to name
it after James Webb right who's not a
scientist I think he's the first
telescope is not named after a scientist
wow but he was head of NASA while we
were going to the Moon wow that's a
that's that's a pretty big deal yeah
it's a big deal the James Webb Space
Telescope scheduled to be launched
in 2021 it's been delayed because it's
like
it's Unique design and Engineering you
don't pull that stuff off the shelf no
okay in fact the telescope is so large
it doesn't fit in the fairing of the
spaceship that's going to launch it
right so they have to take the mirror
and fold it up like the Petals of a
flower okay then the thing gets launched
deployed and then it unfurls nice into
the mirror it's a brilliant engineering
Concepts to make this thing happen but
that sounds dangerous this is tuned to
observe galaxies being born
at the beginning of time wow it is tuned
precisely for that and it can observe
other things all right you can look deep
inside and so it's tuned for infrared to
make that happen and it's got a huge
collecting area so it can look deep
inside of gas clouds because infrared
can penetrate clouds and by the way
that's not something
unusual to people's awareness because
still hot on a cloudy day no no I'm
joking okay
um when it's foggy out you're not
supposed to use your brights right
because they're very blue blue scatters
into clouds and then it looks like a
movie screen the movie screen right so
you use your regular lights but if you
had fog lights it's like they're like
Amber I know yeah right okay they'll
punch right through the cloud oh deep
red lights would punch through even
better infrared the Cloud's not even
there that's right it's transparent to
infrared so you take it infrared pointed
at clouds in the universe you see deep
down in you can see the formation of
brand new stars and planets yeah the
James Webb Space Telescope is especially
tuned to observe infrared light
at an infrared wavelength that forming
galaxies in the beginning of the
universe which at that time are emitting
ultraviolet light
over the lifetime of the University
ultraviolet light redshifts through the
entire visible spectrum and lands in the
infrared
so this telescope was tuned to see the
birth of galaxies in the universe after
they had redshifted for 14 billion years
it turns out infrared is really good for
probing deep gas clouds and seeing
what's going on there high on my
priority list
um well I have a bias because I study
exoplanets and I have so many burning
questions that I want answered so I
really want to look at those first but
the other physics and our astrophysics
that we're doing is super cool for
instance they say that we can detect
traces of the very first supernovae that
went off in the universe that sounds
amazing to be able to see the very first
galaxies kind of the moment when the
lights in the universe licked on that's
tremendously exciting to see the nearest
galaxies in high resolution to the point
where you can make out individual stars
and watch them being born in real time
on a kind of a galactic scale is very
exciting
we have these images from the alma array
which I mentioned earlier which is this
array of sub-millimeter telescopes in
the Atacama Desert who are combining
light to observe
protoplanetary disks where baby planets
are being formed today we see the
material they end up looking like these
complex discs of material that have
structure like thin Rings or spiral
structure and the current thinking is
all of that structure is caused by the
baby planets that are embedded in that
dust and gas with web we will be able to
find the planets themselves and make
sure and verify that that theory that's
what's creating this structure is due to
planets so that's all the other stuff
but what I'm really excited about is to
observe exoplanets in order to resolve
some long-standing mysteries for example
one of the most common actually the most
common type of planet that Kepler
identified and it appears it's one of
the most common types of planets in the
galaxy is a kind of planet we don't even
have in our solar system and we don't
understand their nature we don't
understand if this is more real estate
for life or if it's something completely
exotic and different maybe it's an ocean
World a planet like Earth it's
completely enveloped in an ocean we
don't know so I'm very excited to
observe those planets and figure that
out we got to love Hubble because of the
beautiful color pictures it sent back to
us if most of what you're doing is
spectra making is in the analysis of
rainbows
then people will rely on the science you
say comes from it rather than from their
desktop picture that they put from the
telescope itself well we'll just quickly
um Webb will take beautiful images as
well it has cameras on board that are
taking images so you will see some
fantastic new Vistas but I think the
transformational science is in the what
we call spectroscopy Neil will let me
say that word other news outlets have
have told me not to say that word you
already said rainbow you already said
rainbow so we'll kick it up a notch
since we we got the rainbow
so spectroscopy is the study of rainbows
and we the the rainbow of light carries
so much information with it that's how
we learn about the universe and so one
thing Webb could do is to really see
this notion into the public
Consciousness about how we utilize
rainbows to learn about the universe
that already would be a tremendous Leap
Forward for our Collective Consciousness
but in addition to that we're going to
learn so much about all of these
different objects and really what I'd
like to say is web might not be designed
for Life as a life detector but it is
one way station on the way there and the
decadal survey already put forward the
plan for the next Flagship Mission
Beyond web which will be that life
finder and it's going to make use of all
of the physics that we learned about how
planets form evolve and and what makes a
planet potentially habitable and where
the most likely abodes of Life are are
going to be so that we are well
positioned to use that telescope that
comes later and you will be alive if you
are in high school today you will be
alive when that first discovery of a
living world hits the headlines remind
us where this thing is getting planted
it's not just in Earth orbit like Hubble
that's right it's in a very special
place and uh this particular place is
behind the Earth in in what we would
call the Earth's Magneto tail okay and
it's called Uh L2 it's a new anatomical
part you know yes
it sounds like a new X-Man
magnetotale that's right so so that's
that's how you remember to pronounce
magnetosphere correctly is think of
Magneto and then put a sphere on the end
of it good there you go nice all right
so this is on the other side of the moon
right
no it's directly behind the Earth in
line from the Earth to the Sun
oh interesting L2 is behind us and and
it's a unique place because what's
happening is uh in that location it's
really orbiting the Sun
but because it's behind the Earth it
would move slower around the Sun than
the Earth does
but here's where the Earth comes in the
Gravity from from the Earth
pulls it along
and so not only the Sun's gravity but
the Earth's gravity keeps it in a nice
position we call L2 which is like 920
million miles away from the earth so
this has nothing to do with the Moon
Moon keeps doing its orbit around the
Earth right like it like nothing's
happening while this spacecraft is still
out there is there a mode the telescope
can go in
that is because what I'd always loved
even telling the public about that we do
as scientists is of course you design an
instrument for what you intend to find
all right that's how you know what the
parameters are and what the specs should
be but is there a mode where it's just
looking for nothing
like a Serendipity mode so in case
something shows up that nobody ordered
nobody was looking for and we end up
scratching our head when it shows up
like every other telescope in New York
City whatever
well uh like Hummel you know which
decided okay we've got some spare time
let's just stare in an area and then
found the you know fabulous array of
galaxies that it did there'll probably
be some time when we will you know look
in a particular area and then just turn
it on and see what we find but at the
moment it's really well subscribed as we
would say you know we have a hundred
hours uh uh open to the planetary
scientists to make a variety of
measurements of solar system objects
that data will come in and be available
to all the other planetary scientists
and and then many of the astronomers uh
will have already accepted proposals and
they'll be uh you know following
following that schedule that they've
created but that won't really kick in
until six months after launch so each
image then Nicole represented a branch
of study for the telescope's abilities
so I we got one which was the distant
Universe early galaxies
um gravitational lensing we have your
Spectra of the chemistry of exoplanets
so what were the other three yes so we
have
um a another galaxy image but it was an
in-depth called Stefan's quintet and so
it's five galaxies that are relatively
nearby and they're interacting so that's
a really neat thing there and so you see
it love me yeah and what do you mean
what do you mean by interacting oh so
all galaxies are always moving and away
from each other or moving towards each
other and so this is a grouping where
they eventually can basically come
together and morph into each other and
like strip each other of stars and
whatever to form a brand new Galaxy
later on and what's what's fun about it
is when Galax galaxies are extended
objects they're not points of of gravity
they're extended and so when two
galaxies see each other yeah they feel
each other's gravitational forces they
begin to distort each other according to
the strength of gravity
across their their physical size which
is not the same right because if you're
the distance Point that's going to feel
a little less gravity than the point
that's close up and so as a result you
get this shredding of a galaxy as it
comes near another it's a beautiful it's
like a beautiful train wreck
um would you agree Nicole it's they're
gorgeous
yeah also okay the most mind-blowing
thing to me about that quintet is all
the galaxies behind it too there's just
like like the field is photobombed with
galaxies essentially so okay the ones in
front are fascinating absolutely but
then it's like behind there what the
heck is going on oh my gosh because I
grew up you know because like I said me
and Stefan's quintet go way back but in
the pictures of Stefan's quintet that's
kind of the only action in the photo
so you're saying so you're saying the
James Webb Space Telescope
even if your professional scientific
interest is Stefan's Quintet
somebody else might be able to use the
data that happened to be in the
background of your image to study
something else yes there's this data
there's galaxies everywhere essentially
okay so now we've got three of the
images what are the other two so there
was also an image of a dying star
so it's a planetary nebula they call it
but it's one of these beautiful it has
like shells of material around it
basically the star has died a star like
our sun and it has evolved and shed its
outer layers over time and it's created
these like bubbles of material where
there's interactions with gas heating
each other heating other gas up and and
spreading elements out through the
universe so it's like this beautiful
transition of a Dying star and it's
feeding the universe now does that have
a colloquial name for it
um for that nebula it does
because Chuck we we name our stuff
whatever this thing looks like we name
it uh you know there's a Pac-Man nebula
out there do you know that I saw that
the Pac-Man which I love what's the
dying star in nebula it's the southern
Ring Nebula okay
not even interesting Southern ring okay
but if you look at the image yeah
there's there's a bunch of rings like of
materials so yeah I think that's where
they didn't come from as creative as
others named up there yeah cool okay you
need one more image okay then there's
Karina this is a region another nebula
yeah with star formation but this one is
like zoomed in you're seeing just
incredible amounts of gas and dust like
you're seeing through the gas and dust
to see stars forming behind it and
heating up the gas and dust and I'm
telling you you have to look at these
images high resolution online you know
because you can just zoom in for days
and see this material you just keep
zooming in yeah something you couldn't
do with Hubble you can zoom in a little
bit and that was good in it today right
oh my God we're not we're not done you
know this is just the beginning
allow me to remind us
that unlike Hubble which orbited Earth
360 miles up this thing is parked
A Million Miles Away
in the opposite direction of the sun
from the earth it's pretty wild okay
yeah and so I say parked we're all or it
and the Earth are orbiting the Sun
together and
so it so basically if you look back in
the earth Direction the sun will always
be there it has some motion where it is
okay but it's not going to drift away
from that location even though there is
some movement within the location the
the point is occasionally Earth will
block the Sun but the value of this is
you always know which way the sun is
right at all times okay
behind you okay right all right if
you're going to take a picture of
something that's dim
you either have to illuminate it
yourself
which we really can't do for the early
the universe that doesn't work or you
can take a long exposure
to allow the light to accumulate but
while you're taking that warming
exposure you can't jiggle the camera it
has to be perfectly stationary so Chuck
just to repeat we can't take a flash
picture of the outer universe so we have
to open the exposure for a long time
okay so now watch uh different
bands of the electromagnetic spectrum
tell us different things about the
universe
right so if you're going to do that you
need telescopes that specialize in the
chosen band and by the way we didn't
even know light came in bands other than
visible light
somebody had to discover that I mean
just think about it why would you have
any inkling
why would you believe at all that there
was a kind of light out there that your
eyes could not detect right here's the
cool thing about the James Webb
Telescope it has a special reflective
surface on its mirrors
that are tuned to reflect infrared with
very high efficiency that's number one
reflect and focus number two if you're
trying to detect something that is a
very low temperature
what happens if you have a temperature
and you're the detector you end up
detecting yourself exactly so so you
need a way to cool the telescope so we
could send up cryogenic liquids and
things but they would eventually
evaporate or or gain temperature and
that so what we figured out to do we not
I the engineers who are tasked with this
um that telescope has a series of
thermal baffles
between it and the Sun
all right and so those just take a look
at any photo of the full telescope
deployed these these they're basically
screened they're like sheets that are
that are put up a series of of them in
the row so sunlight comes and hits one
of them it reflects some back
others get absorbed and gets
re-transmitted to the next sheet but
that gets
resent back there's this multiple triple
Reflections and at each layer the amount
of heat from the Sun is dramatically
dropped
okay dramatic by the time it comes out
the other side is barely there at all
and so the temperature of the telescope
can now drop
to what is basically the temperature of
deep space without any influence of
sunlight
uh increasing its its body temperature
if you will that's wild so the things
like the James Webb Telescope will that
make us think about the calibration of
time and the universe in a different way
or just it literally Enlighten us that's
awesome excellent question so all it
will quote simply do is take us to a
place in time forgive me for using a
place and a Time reference in one
sentence take us to a place in time yeah
where
galaxies are being born so we get to
fill in the storyline so you go back to
the previous end zone so the James Webb
Space Telescope if I just did a fast
calculation in real time uh we'll go
back to the seven yard line it's a lot
of universe between one end zone and the
other but what that means is we will
have access
to almost the entire playing field
almost the entire timeline of the
universe right from seven yards up to
100 yards this is an extraordinary
Triumph of modern astrophysics
enabled empowered by brilliant engineers
that enable us to to work with this
telescope to begin with the James Webb
Space Telescope fighting galaxies that
should not be existing that soon after
the big bang how is that going to change
thoughts in cosmology and how the early
Universe formed okay let me back that up
a second and come back to you when to
hear Wendy why it should there be a time
in the early Universe where we don't
expect galaxies wait what's going on
the very earliest moments of the
universe we had of course Big Bang
radiation from The Big Bang couldn't
reach us early on there was a very hot
plasma and it was too hot even for
hydrogen atoms to form so the photons
from The Big Bang would hit the
electrons in this plasma
and and we don't have any information
there at about 380
000 years after the big bang the
expansion had proceeded to the point
where the temperature had cooled enough
that you could form a hydrogen
and after that the photons from The Big
Bang could stream out and we can detect
them today they're all around the
background radiation has been detected
from The Big Bang then with telescopes
like Hubble we can peer back into the
universe and with Hubble we can go maybe
12 billion years back in time we could
see tiny little smudges that Hubble
could barely resolve and you you
couldn't get detailed information on
those this is 12 billion out of nearly
14 billion so that's pretty far back
that's pretty good right 12 out of 14.
very very good but there's a region of a
space of time that we have actually
referred to as the Dark Ages which is
the period between when we can first
detect photons from The Big Bang 380 000
years after the big bang and maybe 12
billion years ago and and we have no
information about that time so one of
the main scientific goals of the J James
Webb is to study the Dark Ages and to
see galaxies forming witnessing directly
the first galaxies to form so we know
they're there we're in a galaxy we can
see these faint smudges but we have no
information or had no information about
that process and that's what's exciting
about James Webb is we're opening up a
whole new window and we needed an
infrared telescope to do that so but
aren't these galaxies weren't they found
in the Dark Ages I mean you wouldn't
expect that right
these new galaxies were finding yes they
are very they seem to have formed very
early on after after the big bang so
that you know and you're cool and you're
okay with that
I'm okay with that I mean I'm okay with
whatever the universe did I'm not going
to tell the universe
so that's our job measure it and you
know I think that's one of the reasons
why I was excited about James Webb is we
had lots of theories for how Galax
information would happen and and you
know we're pretty certain about those
things but then you actually go and look
and you learn something new what we
learn I'm not sure yet I think we have
more surprises yet in store
and in a way that's the whole point of
the telescope right yeah yeah and and so
right now there's this I think
um excitement that maybe galaxies very
massive galaxies form very early on and
our current theories tell us there was
no time to do that you can't possibly
have galaxies that are that massive that
early
but I think we need to explore a lot of
other questions about you know what were
the stars like that formed early on are
they the same as the ones that are
forming today what was is there dust in
the early universe that we don't know
about or the properties different was
the star formation rate different
the way that they form the distribution
of masses so there's a lot of exploring
I think we need to do so you'll see
headlines like you know the Big Bang is
dead and
um standard cosmology is broken and I
think we need to just slow down a little
and and really understand what we're
seeing which is really interesting but
we don't yet know I think what it means
what is the usable lifespan of jwst
and when it runs out of station keeping
fuel or whatever it is
is that enough into the future so that
at this L2 Point since you said earlier
that could be a a place where other
telescopes hang out might it be a place
that astronauts visit to maybe refuel it
and keep it going such good questions
okay first of all humans what we fall in
love by like what the fifth date that's
pretty quick right I made that up that
statistic okay but we fall in love
pretty quickly and and Webb will give us
five to ten years so it's Baseline for
five but it has enough consumed Mobiles
on board to last for 10 that is
significantly different than Hubble and
it's out at L2 where it's not
serviceable yet or now the plan I hope I
think I've seen a little bit of is to
create a CIS Lunar Station and from a
CIS Lunar Station it's like a like the
International Space Station but it's out
closer to the orbit of the moon and when
you get out at those distances you don't
need a very big velocity kick you know
slingshot velocity rocket velocity kick
to get out to L2 it's easier so if we
can do that we should be able to build
telescopes at L2 service telescopes at
L2 send astronauts out there and back
keep in mind that the L2 is four times
further away than the moon is so it's
it's a million miles away it's quite a
long distance but even though that
sounds really far and difficult assist
Lunar Station would help to make that a
reality and I do think that's part of
the long-term plan not within the next
10 years though so once the astronauts
do get out there to L2 or their robots
it would probably be archaeological not
active archaeological wow I like that so
so the future Frontier science I one day
will be archaeological for a Next
Generation right that that
simultaneously beautiful and disturbing
foreign